und was wirklich dass er mich ja ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass ich mag dass du
manchmal arrogant und faul ist das wenn
sie nicht so toll dass du dein studium
geschmissen aus dem taxi zu fahren das
findet sie schrecklich aber das tun wir
alle zu ertragen
ich kann es nicht mehr hören vor allem
weil wir wahrscheinlich alle rechte
ich denke mal drüber nach wenn ihr was
ein jo-jo liegt vielleicht solltest du
lieber darüber nachdenken ihr das auch
mal zu sagen denn heute abend wird sie
sich mit band treffen
das hat melina erzählt da brauchen wir
keine sorgen zu machen sie versucht sich
ständig mit dem vogel zu treffen und
dann doch nicht auf und wenn es diesmal
doch tut willst du den kern nicht mal
ansehen was man essen
hallo
hallo karla hör mal ich muss unbedingt
wird direkt
ich hab versucht dich anzurufen aber du
bist nicht drangekommen kann soll also
ich habe mich bewusst dass dorfmark
stehst dann hätte ich doch etwas was
hast du denn ich wollte mal unbedingt
wiederhaben
ich habe alles versucht ja und
offensichtlich hast du es bis in sein
bett geschafft was nein ich habe im
wohnzimmer geschlafen auf der couch also
ich habe schon gehofft die nacht in
seinen weg zu verbringen aber mag wollte
nicht hat anderes im kopf
freundin